artificial intelligence is
revolutionizing agriculture by providing
Farmers with powerful analytics tools
that boost crop yields and farming
efficiency Aid driven Technologies can
analyze vast amounts of data from soil
conditions weather patterns and crop
Health in real time for instance
Predictive Analytics can forecast
optimal planting times and suggest the
best crop varieties for specific
environments drones and sensors collect
data on plant growth and nutrient levels
allowing Farmers to make informed
decisions this technology minimizes
waste and maximizes output leading to
more sustainable farming practices as AI
continues to evolve its potential to
transform Global agriculture is immense